je vous propose maintenant un débat
politique une confrontation sur les
propositions des deux finalistes
demandez le programme
après les retraites et l'europe gros
plan sur les réformes constitutionnelles
proposées par marine le pen emmanuel
macron la candidate et rennes veut
inscrire la priorité nationale dans la
constitution comment hugo lemonnier
pause les enjeux de notre débat
les institutions s'invite dans
l'entre-deux-tours
premières pistes de réforme la
proportionnelle intégrale la mesure
figure dans le projet du front national
depuis sa création mais cette fois
marine le pen précise elle souhaiterait
une prime majoritaire pour le parti
arrivé en tête aux législatives
en pratique une formation politique
ayant remporté 25 % des suffrages
pourraient ainsi obtenir la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale de son
côté emmanuel macron laisse la porte
ouverte à un nouveau mode de scrutin il
me semble qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'on peut améliorer avoir par exemple
plus de proportionnelle au mieux
représenter l'ensemble des forces
politiques à l'assemblée nationale
intégral
est-ce qu'on peut aller jusque là je n'y
suis pas opposé en ce qui me concerne
proposition d'un septennat renouvelables
renforcement des prérogatives du
parlement emmanuel macron multiplie les
pistes de réflexion mais reste flou sur
ses intentions le président-candidat
préfère s'en remettre à un accord entre
formations politiques une commission
transpartisane avec toutes les
sensibilités politiques qu'ils puissent
ensuite soumettre aux deux assemblées
une proposition de réforme de notre
constitution pour précisément la rénover
l'améliorer elle dispose d'un texte
prête à voter avec l'introduction de la
priorité nationale la réforme du droit
d'asile et de la nationalité française
marine le pen prévoit dès son entrée en
fonction un référendum comprenant une
révision de la constitution
c'est beaucoup plus sain que ce soit le
peuple qui le vote je trouve plutôt que
les deux chambres et je pense même je
veux dire que seul le peuple devrait
avoir la possibilité de réviser la
constitution
déjà critiquée par des juristes de tous
bords politiques
la candidate du rassemblement
nationale est accusé de vouloir
contourner le parlement et de compte
revenir ainsi à la jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel en réponse à ces
attaques marine le pen brandit le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
supposé introduire un renouveau
démocratique
et ça c'est vraiment une garantie pour
le peuple français qui est une garantie
totale cinq cent mille signatures pour
pouvoir soit proposé une loi au vote
soit abroger une loi qui aurait été
votée c'est vraiment rendre le pouvant
plus et c'est cela que je veux faire
rarement les institutions auront été
autant au coeur du débat dans
l'entre-deux tours d'une élection
présidentielle
et pour débattre autour d'eux des
propositions de marine le pen et
d'emmanuel patron des sur les
institutions j'accueille yaël boon
peavey bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
député les oem des yvelines présidente
de la commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale andré acosta raj bon soir soit
la mieux vaut aussi président du groupe
fn au conseil régional d'auvergne et
rhône alpes ain charline bezina bons
soient ou non soit institutionnaliste
maître de conférences en droit public
vous nous éclairer sur ce qui est le
droit aujourd'hui laetitia khl pas été
respectées qu'à laisser à mes côtés
évidemment andrée côté match commence
avec avec vous avec ce référendum sur un
projet de loi révisant la constitution
pour y inscrire la priorité nationale le
modèle de marine le pen si j'ai bien
compris c'est 1962 c'était il ya
soixante ans et depuis le rôle du
constitue du conseil cautionner a quand
même changé notamment depuis 2000 est ce
que vous faites comme si de rien n'était
d'abord je remercie non le révision
constitutionnelle vous l'avez résumé la
priorité nationale ce qui est
complètement faux je crois que d'abord
avant de proposer des choses ont fait un
constat le constat c'est que dans notre
pays on a une crise démocratique le
constat c'est pas la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle je le constate c'est
que aujourd'hui dans notre pays on a eu
un président de la république qui quand
même avait promis un référendum
notamment lors de la convention
citoyenne puis thil a retiré on a eu un
président en 2017 un candidat qui nous
avait promis à la proportionnelle il l'a
oublié mais apparemment ça lui revient à
l'esprit puisqu'il leur propose à
nouveau il trouve ça très bien mais ne
l'a jamais fait vous avez eu une crise d
gilet jaune qui demandaient notamment du
pouvoir d'achat mais qui demande aussi
une idée assez simple le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne c'est à dire
redonner un souffle à la démocratie
quelle a été la réponse de monsieur
maxence 2500 blessés selon amnistie
internationale donc vous voyez qu'on a
une crise moi je suis élu régional élu
local et j'ai pas peur de dire que mon
assemblée sel dans lequel je siège n'est
pas légitime dans les élections
régionales on a eu 82 % des jeunes qui
se sentent abstenus est-ce qu'on accepte
oui ou non la véritable réponse est non
évidemment que non vous prenez des
analyses comme céline pina qui l'avait
fait dans causeur sur l'abstention
depuis les années 60 mais elle baisse
constamment toutes élections confondues
est-ce qu'on accepte ou pas la
démocratie c'est quoi c'est le règlement
des conflits pacifique c'est le
règlement par le vote si on n'a pas un
renouveau démocratie dans notre pays on
aura la violence moi je propose la
démocratie avec marine le pen bon il
vous répondrait à la question sur la
priorité nationale tout âge répond tout
de suite non non non je voulais les
lapins volailles n sauf la france je lui
ai donné la parole à yale brive et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
réforme constitutionnelle qui est
proposée par marine le pen bah écoutez
moi elle me semble aberrante sur le fond
et sur la forme sur le fond parce que
elle revient sur l'ensemble de des
droits et des libertés sur lesquels on a
fondé notre république elle revient sur
la déclaration des droits de l'homme de
1789 puisque la priorité nationale
contrevient au principe d'égalité tout
simplement les propositions que l'on
peut égrainer la préférence nationale
pour les allocations sociales ça revient
sur le préambule de 1946 bref on peut
prendre par dizaines et par dizaines les
propositions de marine le pen contenus
dans son programme elles contreviennent
à une série de principes
constitutionnels qui nous protège son
aux droits et libertés la liberté
d'aller et venir la liberté de culte
quand elle parle du voile la liberté de
manifestation enfin toutes nos libertés
serait atteinte et la façon de le faire
parce qu'elle sait très bien que le
parlement ne laisserai pas faire que le
conseil constitutionnel ne laisserai pas
refait pas faire parce que nos
institutions sont ainsi faite qu'elle
repose sur un équilibre de pouvoir sur
des pouvoirs qui se contrebalancent ce
contrôle les uns les autres et qu'est ce
qu'elle fait et bien en appelle au
peuple au principe majoritaire et là
elle contrevient sur la forme
puisqu'elle sait très bien qu'elle n'a
pas le droit de le faire qu'elle n'a pas
le droit de le faire et elle utilise
l'article 11 vous expliquerez ce qu'il
ya dedans tout à l'heure dans un instant
à chânes bill l'article 11 de la
constitution est ce que c'est pour
marine le pen à un moyen de contourner
l'état de droit non mais d'abord parce
que dit il ya le bruit vers l'instant
d'abord je peux pas laisser passer les
énormités qui vient d'être dit
absolument pas on a eu vous l'aï dit
depuis cinquante-huit reconstitution on
a eu peu de référendum mais 27
modifications sans l'avis du peuple
france ça nous a pas dérangé on a eu
dans notre pays un référendum un traité
pour une constitution européenne rédigée
par la commission européenne et par le
comité de bâle et dirigiste car destin
dont tous les médias d or pour on
retrouve l'ambiance tout le monde était
pour le oui le peuple a dit non on
retrouve la même ambiance tout le monde
et pour mac rond mais le peuple je crois
et l'ira marine le pen je me sois
playfrance iranien soit pour macro mais
bref lepage deux français pouvaient dire
ça si vous le soulever le peuple plaisir
mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
peuple français si je peux terminer
avait répondu non et nicolas sarkozy
soutien de monsieur maquereau
a trahi peuple français en faisant
passer le traité de lisbonne sans l'avis
du peuple français encore une fois ça ne
vous a absolument pas dérangée
aujourd'hui marine le pen dit moi je
veux redonner des droits français je
veux leur donner notamment l'initiative
législative citoyenne avait quelque
chose à ces détails et c'est quoi
l'avantagé référendum d'initiative
citoyenne c'est un la pacification du
débat c'est à dire retrouver une culture
démocratique comme on peut la voir dans
certains autres pays mais pardon je sais
retrouver la proportion pour normand la
route alors ils repèrent avec une ryoko
tani excusez moi je verse une seconde
série que je vais prendre moi je vais
reprendre la main une seconde parce que
on va en parler du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne c'est prévu le
débat dure 40 minutes ne vous inquiétez
pas vous répondez pas du tout à la
question sur l'article 11 est ce que
c'est un moyen de contourner les tailles
de droit ou pas si vous voulez merci à
grands pas la question c'est aussi ça
une émission avec un journaliste et un
invité politique aucun problème merci de
vos questions d'ailleurs je suis juriste
aussi de république je remercie que vous
soyez là effectivement il ya un débat
sur l'article 11 effectivement le
conseil constitutionnel et vous le
dirais certainement s'est arrogé
certains droits notamment de contrôler
notamment de bloquer certains va faire
un double c'est une vision qu'on peut
avoir moi ce que je constate au delà des
des droits du conseil qu'au ciel au
droit des juges que monsieur maquereau a
nommé notamment puisque le conseil
constitutionnel à la base dans l'esprit
de la constitution c'était des juges les
sages au dessus de la constitution je
crois et c'est ma théorie mais je sais
que dans la doctrine il ya débat c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu un organe
politique avec une majorité et une
minorité donc est ce qu'on peut
considérer que les personnes nommées qui
ne sont pas élus peuvent justement
s'arroger certains droits et bloquer
certaines choses moi le constat que je
fais vraiment je vous le dit avec
émotion même et conviction c'est que la
démocratie dans notre pays ne fonctionne
plus c'est que des gens s'abstiennent
c'est le dirait un quart d'heure de
simplifier contre l'abstention tout le
monde est d'accord ayant loupé sur la
proportionnelle et respectez pas de
référendum oui on tue la démocratie et
supprimant anne charrier de bezina avoue
ce champ de l'article 11 est ce que la
priorité nationale je sais quand même ce
qui est privé est ce que ça rentre dans
le champ de l'article on sait tel qu'il
est défini aujourd'hui alors
actuellement non ça c'est une évidence
dans le champ de l'article 11 on à
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics les
questions économiques sociales
environnementales et éventuellement les
problèmes de ratification de traités qui
pourrait poser problème à la
souveraineté de la nation
un homme pour ces questions alors le
champ du référendum n'est pas immuable
un an 95 ya eu une réforme
constitutionnelle justement pour élargir
ce champ du référendum dont on pourrait
tout à fait élargir ce champ du
référendum mais pour ça il faudrait
modifier la constitution donc
actuellement le champ du référendum et
celui ci voilà après j'entendais
beaucoup de choses il ya je crois qu'il
faut pas opposer le conseil
constitutionnel au peuple là la question
de savoir s'il est nommé s'il est mal
nommée c'est quelque chose qu'on
pourrait mener évidemment il ya beaucoup
de cour constitutionnelle qui sont
nommés différemment qui sont nommés par
le parlement était déjà bon il ya
évidemment des choses à réfléchir là
dessus néanmoins c'est pas tant le
conseil constitutionnel dont on parle là
à l'heure actuelle c'est le texte même
de la constitution et ce texte même de
la constitution il faut rappeler qu'il a
été choisi par le peuple français donc
nous constituons des niçois toujours
dans une position un petit peu dommage
de se dire on oppose peut-être parfois
le texte à la démocratie alors que la
démocratie passe également par le texte
ou alors elle n'est plus la démocratie
et dans ce cas là il faut aller vers
mettre les choses à baham alors il faut
accepter de mettre les choses à plat
change de république et qu'on change de
consignation du tout et qu'on change le
conseil constitutionnel alors à son
jeune âge il faut si je crois enfin pour
le coup il ya vraiment un débat moi
j'étais juriste en droit public moi
j'étais à l'université lyon iii et jeu
c'est énorme plus diplômés puisque vous
avez continué aux études derrière mais
jean jacques rousseau
disait la constitution et la norme
suprême il rajoutait qu un peuple libre
se donne la constitution a été modifiée
27 fois sans le peuple français
on peut pas dire ça serait faux de dire
on ne peut pas gouverner par référendum
et vous avez tout à fait raison on peut
gouverner par référendum on peut
gouverner avec le parlement on peut
gouverner avec le parlement et le
référendum nôtres normalement notre
système depuis 10 791 c'est l'article 3
aussi bien la déclaration des droits de
l'homme que de la constitution c'est
d'avoir une souveraineté une démocratie
qu'on appelle semis direct c'est-à-dire
à la fois de la représentation
parlementaire est à la fois le peuple
alors consulter le peuple c'est tout à
fait possible on dit souvent le
référendum il est enfermé dans des
carcans c'est faux c'est tout à fait
possible la seule chose c'est que
souvent le parlement représente le
pluralisme et donc on a tendance à
penser que à partir du moment où une
réforme constitutionnelle doit susciter
l'adhésion elle doit aussi pouvoir
susciter l'adhésion d'un parlement qui
généralement doit travailler avec ce
président c'est l'idée qui précise que
je vais évoquer rapidement tout à
l'heure il faut il faut détailler le
conseil constitutionnel peut être saisi
en cas de dudu koidu de ce qu'il ya dans
le référendum c'est ça éventuellement
retoque est l'objet du référendum
pas de réponse fixe là dessus il faut le
dire c'est vrai qu'en 62 le général de
gaulle a utilisé une procédure qui est
totalement parra constitutionnel qu'il
m'a prévenu que la procédure de
l'article 11 et personne n'a rien trouvé
à y redire puisque rien ne permet tait
de contrer sa volonté néanmoins c'est
vrai que depuis 2000 le conseil
constitutionnel proposant sa
jurisprudence d'avoir un contrôle assez
exceptionnel mais à ses fins du décret
de convocation des électeurs juste pour
vérifier d'autres cour constitutionnelle
le fond et ça fait partie du test
vérifier que les conditions sont donc la
condition ici aurait tendance à ne pas
être rempli étant donné qu'on n'est pas
passé par la bonne procédure donc on dit
souvent et ça fait partie aussi du
programme de dire que le conseil
cantonal de contrôle plus l'est loi
référendaire c'est vrai il ne le fait
pas mais la procédure référendaire il
pourrait le faire je vais vous donner la
parole tout de suite il ya une bonne pub
parce que c'est intéressant c'est
vraiment on est dans programme les
projets contre-projet il ya cette idée
de commission transpartisane que
proposait même a convenu vous dites
référendum on va au peuple et là il ya
une commission transpartisane donc c'est
quoi c'est la recherche d'une sorte
d'unanimité via les représentants des
partis politiques existants c'est
exactement ça l'idée c'est que pour
réformer notre démocratie nous
souhaitons avoir et créer les conditions
d'un consensus des différentes forces
politiques du pays voir avec les
citoyens et les corps intermédiaires il
nous semble que ce sujet est trop
important et trop primordial aujourd'hui
pour être l'objet d'affrontements de
camp contre camp et qu'il faut aller
rechercher ce qui pourrait nous
rassembler dans cet esprit de rénovation
par des interviews que cette vème
république a besoin d'une rénovation
mais moi j'ai fait un rapport sur le
parlement pour justement proposer des
solutions pour avancer moi je crois que
la vème république et la cinquième à la
constitution de la vème république et
dans son architecture un modèle
d'équilibré on voit bien que les
pouvoirs se s'équilibre mutuellement et
quand on dit le conseil constitutionnel
ce sont des gens nommés mais ce sont des
gens nommés par le président de la
république par le président du sénat par
le président d'assemblée nationale ya
passage avec des auditions et des votes
des deux commissions des lois assemblée
nationale et sénat qui n'ont pas les
mêmes représentativité vous voyez bien
qu'on a une architecture qui à mon sens
est très protectrice et donc il faut à
mon sens garder cet équilibre des
pouvoirs en revanche il fois avancé nous
avions souhaité avancer en 2017 nous
avions proposé une loi sur la
proportionnelle nous avions proposé un
certain nombre de raisons qui ont été
partie des promesses qui malheureusement
n'ont pas pu être tenus nous avons
essayé moi j'étais rapporteur de la loi
constitutionnelle aux côtés de richard
film alors c'est quoi de notre faute
sa cible non c'est pas un peu facile
c'est justement parce que nous avons
besoin d'un large consensus pour
réformer nos institutions et que nous
n'avons pas réussi à l'obtenir en posant
sur la table nos projets que nous nous
disons aujourd'hui ce projet il faut que
nous le construisons ensemble pour
pouvoir y parvenir nous nous souhaitions
faire de toute façon apaisée et
consensuelle quand d'autres souhaitent
tenter le coup de force et en appeler au
peuple et donc à la majorité sans
regarder sans chercher ces faux
l'apaisement et la construction positive
dans notre pays il faut qu emmanuel
macron cette fois sidérée et lui donne
des gages tout de suite de cette réforme
institutionnelle villa oui qu'il a
promises il y a cinq ans parce que vous
savez bien qu'on ne commence pas un
quinquennat en laissant de côté et puis
moitié du quinquennat tiens on va
réformer les institutions or l'entourage
emmanuel macron pour l'instant quand on
les écoute nous disent bon cette réforme
institutionnelle on la fera c'est pas
dans l'urgence et le problème c'est que
l'on est face à une crise de la
démocratie représentative ça tout le
monde peut le constater et donc marine
le pen évidemment
l'instrumentalise assassa son voile à
son avantage et donc il faut bien que
l'autre quand l'autre finaliste emmanuel
macron puisse lui opposer une promesse
et qu'il tiendra prend la parole je vous
la donne et ensuite on parle précisément
du référendum d'initiative citoyenne ou
populaire avec plaisir votre façon sur
le sur le référendum d'initiative
populaire contrairement à ce qui a été
dit ce mécanisme ne permettra pas de
modifier la constitution donc pas de
modifier l'article 66 1 sur la mort donc
pas de modifier parlions pas de
s'engager loi sur la préférence
nationale mais vous vous ramenez
toujours on joue au référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et vous gommez
tout le reste des propositions qui sont
contraires à la constitution à nos
principes et nos droits et libertés qui
sont très attentatoire à l'est et vous
ramener toujours tout au référendum ça
n'est pas le sujet madame c'est
extraordinaire d'avoir des gens qui
passent leur temps à la télévision en
disant que nous sommes contre la
démocratie nous rassemblement national
et quand on serait précisément donné un
souffle démocratique donner des pouvoirs
au peuple et donc la vie sur le
territoire on nous explique que nous
soyons démagogues et c'est
extraordinaire ce que j'ai vu sur les
libertés fondamentales
celui qui a en tout cas massacres et de
mon point de vue mais en tout cas qui a
posé question sur les libertés
fondamentales durant son quinquennat
notamment dans la crise de lakovic 19 je
crois que c'est emmanuel macron celui
qui a commis de la violence je le répète
amnistie internationale expliquait 2500
blessés lors des manifestations du gilet
jaune c'est pas marie la bonne c'est
monsieur castaner et monsieur maxence
pas moi qui le dit c'est un site interne
par conséquent arrêtons ces anathèmes
parlons du fond sur le fond je vous le
dis il ya la juriste qui a parlé et à la
raison il ya un équilibre des pouvoirs
parce que le parlement notamment
l'international est censé représenter la
pluralité des opinions moi mon point de
vue c'est que l'assemblée nationale avec
une participation au moins 50%
législatives avec 577 députés seulement
8 du rassemblement national alors que
nous présentons des millions de français
ne représente pas la clé réalités
fonctionnelles reviendra ce référendum
d'initiative citoyenne j'appelle
alexandre poussard bas salaires dans une
minute mais je n'ai un style salut
alexandre bienvenus on va d'abord écouté
marine le pen parce que marine le pen
elle elle propose vraiment une
révolution référendaire on écoute je
propose ici une révolution référendaire
la constitution sera révisé d'abord pour
rendre plus facile l'organisation de
référendum sur tous les sujets ensuite
et surtout pour instaurer le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne appelé aussi
référendum d'initiative populaire alors
justement alexandre poussa un peu de
pédagogie ça existe dans de nombreux
pays est ce que ça marche alors on met
des gens on va dire que il ya et bien un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
est permis dans une quinzaine de pays
européens on va regarder la carte de ces
pays il y avait bien beaucoup ce système
notamment dans les pays d'europe de
l'est ça fait partie de l'héritage
communiste un peu moins en europe de
l'ouest mais en tout cas il ya un pays
d'europe occidentale où le référendum
citoyen marche très bien c'est
évidemment la suisse avec les fameuses
votation citoyenne alors déjà ça fait
longtemps qu'elles sont instaurées
depuis
1848 elles sont assez fréquents de
plusieurs fois par an au total il y a
déjà eu à 654 votation citoyenne et puis
sur ses 650 cas de votation est bien 315
ont été acceptées par les votants et ont
permis de changer un lillois suisse avec
un taux de participation moyen sedin et
ryan et de 46% alors ces votations
suisses elles se font sur des sujets
divers par exemple en 2009 et bien une
votation a débouché sur l'interdiction
de la construction des minarets en 2001
c'est l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse qui a été légalisé grâce à une
votation citoyenne et les femmes suisses
ont le droit de vote en 1971 également
grâce à une votation citoyenne seulement
en 1961 tous les cantons qui comptent en
france c'était 48 ans n'était déjà pas
les premiers bref
la suisse petit pays qui est peut être
propice à ce genre de votation citoyenne
mais il ya aussi un autre grand pays
d'europe qui le fait qu'ils pratiquent
luis et l'italie en italie on parle de
référendum d'initiative populaire avec
cinq cent mille signatures qui sont
nécessaires pour organiser un référendum
uniquement pour abroger une loi
existante et si la majorité des votants
répond positivement à la question posée
et bien il faut quand même une
participation de plus de 50% pour que
cela et au final un effet dans la loi
alors par le passé en italie et bien des
référendum d'initiative populaire ont
permis par exemple de supprimer
ministère de la culture en 1993 de
rendre possible la privatisation de
l'audiovisuel public en 1995 et de
refuser le développement de l'énergie
nucléaire plus récemment à c'était en
2011 et alors le bilan en europe de
l'est cela s'est un peu plus mitigé ah
oui là c'est beaucoup plus mitigé
beaucoup de référendum échoue dans les
pays d'europe de l'est car il ya et bien
un seuil de participation requis pour
valider le résultat d'un référendum par
exemple en slovaquie la participation
moyenne un référendum est de seulement 2
23% et les slovaques avaient pourtant
répondu oui à un référendum qui est
renforcer l'interdiction du mariage
homosexuel mais faute d'une
participation supérieure à 50% et bien
ce référendum a par exemple échoué et
puis en albanie et en serbie ce système
existe mais il n'y a eu pour le moment
aucun référendum d'initiative citoyenne
dans ces pays car eh bien il n'y a pas
assez de signatures récoltées pour
organiser ce référendum à merci
alexandre pour tous ces détails
effectivement il ya des similitudes avec
le système italien puisque vous
le seuil de 500 signatures de citoyens
pour organiser un référendum c'est ce
que propose marine le pen ya une brune
peavey comment vous le on se dit bon le
président macro on a utilisé fao
organisé aucun référendum dans son
quinquennat bon est ce que pour autant
ça pourrait changer pour le suivant et
comment vous analyser cette proposition
de marine le pen est ce que finalement
c'est pas une avancée démocratique de se
dire régulièrement allons poser des
questions aux français mais très précis
il y avait quand même trois
consultations en nouvelle calédonie qui
ont ils eu lieu c'est autre chose mais
si on va être vraiment exact raison
soyons
c'est factuel
on a fait évidemment des grandes
avancées en termes démocratique avec le
grand débat la convention citoyenne donc
on ne peut pas dire que il ne s'est rien
passé sur le plan innovation
démocratique pendant le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro de la même façon que
nous n'avons pas pu aller au bout de nos
révisions constitutionnelles sur le mode
de scrutin etc nous proposions le la
modification du référendum d'initiative
partagée qui existe dans la constitution
depuis 2008 mais qui n'a jamais été
actionnée parce que les seuils sont
beaucoup trop élevés il faut un peu plus
de 4 millions de signatures il a une
masse qu'imagine fois ce qui m'a alors
il a été actionné pour août justement
pour le rôle à la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris mais il n'a pas été
à et eris vous faute de pare-feu de
participation justement parce que les
seuils sont trompés le beaucoup trop
élevé et nous nous proposions dans notre
réforme constitutionnelle d'en baisser
les seuils à un million de citoyens mais
ce que je trouve intéressant dans le
référendum d'initiative partagée c'est
que il combine les citoyens et les
parlementaires il faut un nombre de
citoyens de signatures citoyennes plus
un nombre de signatures de
parlementaires en fait moi ce que je
n'aime pas dans le type de projet qui
est défendu par marine le pen c'est
l'opposition des uns aux autres marine
le pen dans son projet oppose le peuple
à la représentation nationale et de
façon continuelle moi ce que je crois
c'est qu'il faut les combiner pour avoir
une vie démocratique qui soit apaisée et
c'est ce qu'on a là opposons votre
réponse là dessus parce qu'alors
effectivement cas d'école une loi est
votée par le le mans est ce qu'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne 500
mille citoyens qui disent on est contre
ces lois cette loi pour cette ce
référendum pourrait casser le travail
des parlementaires mais quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne c'est ce qui est prévu
d'abord il ya quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas c'est les seuls qui ont
été proposées par nicolas sarkozy
lorsqu'il a réformé la constitution
semaine être dit et il ya des mots
absolument mielleux et amusant de la
part de ma crainte c'est qu'on dit on
n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout de la
réforme quand on n'est pas allé jusqu'au
bout de la réforme ce qu'on n'a pas fait
la réforme est donc on n'a pas respecté
ses promesses qu'on répète cinq ans plus
tard premier point il faut quand même
l'acte et
ensuite je pense qu'il ne faut pas
opposer l'état de droit à la démocratie
non plus
lorsque les britanniques par exemple
votre pour le brésil c'est leur choix
c'est pas le nôtre eh bien les juges ont
tout fait pour invalider cette élection
je veux pas rentrer là dedans le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne ça
permet quoi ca permettent de trancher
des débats qui est parfois son sociétaux
c'est à dire qu'il dépasse complètement
les clivages partisans et politique qui
qui peuvent être tranchées politique moi
je crois que le référendum est justement
tranchée par le vote c'est justement
apaiser la france mais enfin on n'a pas
senti j'ai pas un outil anti parlement
c'est ce qu'on met pas du tout parce que
à travers ce référendum si vous voulez
je les dis je le répète contre un mois
ce qui a été dit encore une fois qu il
faut ce référendum d'initiative
citoyenne ne modifiera pas la
constitution donc ne remettra pas en
cause et droit donc ne remettra pas en
cause cybercrime de menacer votre
référendum sur la prévision nationale
c'est celui là qui remet en cautionnant
juste une france et suivant c'est une
obsession je peux juste répondre à mes
yeux le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne dans ce que j'ai entendu de
marine le pen il peut évidemment abroger
une loi qui vient d'être votée par le
parlement c'est ce qu'à la tique donc
vous a posé le peuple à la démocratie
représentative alors que nous nous
souhaitons les combinés et les associer
ce qui est extraordinaire mais nous
avons nous vous pouvoir assumer des
différences et manuel macro on ne
comprend pas une chose c'est que c'est
pas macro le roi c'est le peuple en
france et dans la démo
[Musique]
ne représente pas la totalité des
français laurent lemaire représente la
nation représente les citoyens et et
encore moins la pluralité des opinions
je pense que le peuple est le mieux à
même de se représenter lui-même sur les
grandes allées il suffit juste sur un
alibi parce que vous avez fait un
reportage très intéressant sur la les
pays où existe le référendum initiative
soit il ya des pays de l'union
européenne il ya des pays comme la
suisse s'est d'ailleurs cantonales c'est
parfois plus locale et ils ont une
culture démocratique que nous n'avons
pas encore malheureusement du fait que
vous n'avez rien fait il ya des
promesses qui n'ont pas été respectées
vous dites on a innové la convention
citoyenne mais allez demander aux
participants de la convention citoyenne
s'ils sont heureux puisque on l'a tout
simplement pas respecté la promesse d'
emmanuel macron de faire affaire
d'hommes et le dernier point c'est sur
la proportionnelle vous auriez dû là
aussi montré une carte mais le seul pays
de l'union européenne que vous sacralisé
qu'il nya qu il n'y a aucune dose de
proportionnelle pas une seule sait le
parlement français c'est à dire que la
lanterne rouge démocratique la lanterne
rouge de la représentativité des
opinions politiques en europe c'est la
france des manuels macron puisqu'ils
n'ont rien fait alors laetitia cru pas
une question qui est un peu provoc à
quoi sert le parlement ou d'y répondre à
cette question oui je marie sur le cas
d'école qui est devenue la crise qu vite
parce que le parlement a été consulté
plus de 10 x 6 x notamment pour examiner
le projet de loi d'urgence sanitaire est
pourtant du côté de l'opposition on a
cessé d'entendre des contestations sur
notamment l'exercice solitaire du
pouvoir fait par emmanuel macron et
c'était le cas par exemple de fabien
roussel c'était en novembre dernier sur
france inter
ce que je regrette profondément
c'est que encore une fois il va y avoir
un conseil de défense qui va se tenir
demain matin en petit comité avec le
président de la république avec des
informations que lui seul aura
et ensuite nous apprendrons tous demain
soir ce qu'il propose est le riddim à
quoi ils marchent sur le parlement a
comme à chaque fois moi ce que
j'aimerais bien en tant que député en
tant que parlementaire c'est que les
informations qu'il va voir demain nous
puissions les avoir aussi et pouvoir
prendre ensemble les décisions qu'il
faut prendre pour la santé de nos
concitoyens
voilà on était en plein vote du projet
de vigilance sanitaire 1 qui a tué le
pass sanitaires et donc c'est pour ça
que je vous pose la question ce soir à
quoi servent les parlementaires si leur
rôle se cantonne finalement à entériner
des décisions qui sont prises par
l'exécutif
car ils ont été quand même consulté les
chefs de partis ils ont été consultés à
matignon ils ont été consultées aussi
par olivier verrons beaucoup de choix au
début de la crise et puis souvent il se
rendait compte que ce qu'on leur avait
proposé par exemple trois propositions
eh ben le choix final n'était même pas
dans les propositions de départ donc
voyez il ya toujours chez les
parlementaires ce sentiment d'être un
peu de voilà de servir d' idiots utiles
à la décision de l'exécutif
pourquoi parce que bien sûr l'exécutif à
la majorité à l'assemblée et donc
normalement si tous les députés sont
présents parce que ça c'est encore une
autre chose mais si tous les députés de
la majorité sont présents normalement
les lois à passe donc je n'arrive à une
autre question est ce que est ce que les
candidats ont dans leur projet les
candidats les deux finalistes pour
l'élection présidentielle des mesures
pour faire exister c'est par là on peut
parler de la proportionnelle dans le
chalet de bezina pour pour donner plus
de poids au parlement effectivement
est-ce que la proportionnelle c'est
c'est la seule solution est ce qu'il
faut découpler par exemple
les deux le temps parlementaire du temps
présidentiel est-ce qu'il faut enfin
voilà il ya plein de ya plein d'options
possibles faire voter en même temps à la
présidentielle et aux législatives
bref il ya cessé de miracles du
constitutionnel la poterne c'est qu'on
peut aller dans le monde entier mais
personne ne fait la même chose et ça
fonctionne alors il ya une petite
réserve c'est que c'est vrai on est très
minoritaire en europe à être sur un
scrutin majoritaire moyens la grande
bretagne quand même aussi qui existe
avec ce scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
so pourquoi nous on y était venu c'est
qu'on avait justement des majorités très
disparates et qu'on n'arrivait pas du
tout à se mettre d'accord néanmoins la
proportionnelle c'est un outil à manier
avec avec une bonne réflexion à avoir
aussi sur la majorité qu'on veut
consolider dont vous dites il ya quand
même besoin d'oxygénation la dose de
proportionnelle on en parle beaucoup la
proportionnelle intégrale on a essayé en
86 et c'est vrai que ça n'avait pas
donné des résultats particulièrement
concluant notamment parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a toujours ce problème de
consolidation des majorités ensuite et
il faut le dire la vème république elle
a réussi cette synthèse d'arriver quand
même à ce que le parlement puisse
s'exprimer et que le président puisse
exprimer la seule chaussée la pratique
très présidentialiste de nos
institutions qui
est j'ai envie de dire une ligne de
force de notre vème république mais qui
fait aussi parfois avec l'adn française
on est un peu bonapartiste dans leur
tout en ayant aussi ce côté troisième
très iiième république et voilà il ya un
conflit qu'on ne peut pas régler à
l'italienne parce que justement les
italiens n'ont aucune place pour le
président de la république donc il
faudra voir mais est-ce que c'est pas
encore plus utile par exemple de
cantonner ou de limiter le recours aux
ordonnances que deux
d'un sujet de la proportionnelle est ce
que ce n'est pas plus simple aussi
d'apprendre à mieux travailler avec du
coup des votes qui pourraient plus utile
la manière aussi d'organiser les débats
il ya beaucoup de choses à réfléchir sur
le parlement en tant que tel qui à mon
avis ne passe pas nécessairement par le
mode de scrutin même si la
proportionnelle on peut évidemment
discuté très librement c'est une loi
ordinaire 1 qui fixe les scrutins donc
c'est quelque chose qui peut être très
facilement discuter les pays où il ya
une part de proportionnelle très
importantes sont pas forcément
ingouvernable parce qu'il ya cette à
cette idée qui courent quoi c'est la
république des partis à calais
gouvernement qui tombe en permanence la
référence avec la forêt publique il faut
assumer deux choix soit une république
des coalitions qui se fait un petit peu
ce que ce que disait le général de
gaulle c'est que il aimait le scrutin à
deux tours pour que les parties arrivent
à faire des tractations mais j'ai envie
de dire devant le peuple et notamment en
le faisant grâce au sortir des urnes
alors que c'est vrai que dans les
scrutins proportionnels très souvent on
a affaire à des gouvernements de
coalition mais qui sont au moins obligés
de s'entendre qu'il ya ce qu'on appelle
des pratiques un peu contractualiste
entre le président et son assemblée pour
arriver à lui proposer justement un cap
qu'elle accepte c'est donc ça se fait un
peu hors du peuple et c'est pour ça
notamment qu' on a on a voilà nous en
france pas forcément cette culture là
néanmoins ce sont évidemment des pays
qui sont gouvernable et la deuxième
chose c'est que il faut assumer une
certaine j'ai envie d'une certaine
lenteur aussi dans le processus
démocratique qu'on a du mal nous a
assumé en france puisqu'on nous dit
toujours que les lois passent trop
lentement qu'on a beaucoup de difficulté
avec ça or c'est vrai que un parlement
proportional east c'est aussi un
parlement qui prend beaucoup de temps à
discuter et à se mettre d'accord donc il
faut il faut assumer la coalition et
assumer le temps de parole et
discussions qui ne sera évidemment pas
le même il ya le brivet la
proportionnelle ça fait partie là aussi
des promesses non tenues de
du candidat macron 2017 ça faisait
partie effectivement des engagements que
nous avions pris nous souhaitons
toujours
adopté une dose de proportionnelle voire
plus et je pense que ça ça sera vraiment
l'objet des discussions dans cette
commission démocratique si emmanuel
macron est réélu il nous faut un
parlement un peu plus représentatif des
français mais qui nous permettent de
gouverner avec une majorité claire et
c'est bien pour ça que lorsque marine le
pen propose une proportionnelle
intégrale elle propose tout de suite un
correctif parce qu'elle veut une
majorité pour gouverner la vème
république est fondée comme cela serait
juste revenir très rapidement sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire moi je les
gérer au parlement depuis deux ans les
treize textes ont été examinés par ma
collection à lui ne serait-ce qu'un
amendement plais bien sûr mais bien sûr
quand on a exonéré les mineurs de 16 ans
du pass vaccinale c'est un amendement
qui vient du parlement et qui regroupe
tous les voeux tous les groupes
justement parce que c'est ce besoin de
tenir compte de cette situation était
partagée par tous les groupes politiques
quand même mais non non nous avons à
chaque fois amendé les textes nous avons
à chaque fois obtenu des accords avec le
sénat sur plus de la moitié des textes
sénat qui n'est pas fait pas partie de
la majorité toutes les occasions émanait
de se consommer parce que mes seins et
fonds sanitaire mais c'est le rôle de
l'exécutif de gérer une crise sanitaire
c'est ça la répartition des pouvoirs de
la 5e et sacré à mais le bal au mans a
joué pleinement si je peux vous dire que
là occupée vincent % d'activité de la
commission des lois de jeu brésil
indiqué qu'ils allaient réagir à la
proportionnelle effectivement que
propose marine le pen précisément mais
précisément j'ai juste un point si c'est
marrant vous répondez jamais alors j'ai
fait d'avoir voté merci c'est sympa si
dans la com site assez simple c'est
qu'en réalité là où on a aussi encore
une caricature on essaye de faire peur
ou proportionnelle avec une prime
majoritaire c'est exactement ce qui se
passe dans les conseils régionaux prime
majoritaire de 25 % c'est exactement ce
qui se passe dans les villes une
majorité de 50% marine le pen ce qu'elle
propose une prime majoritaire de 30%
d'accor où je suis pas sûr que dans les
conseils régionaux la dictature règne
dans les conseils municipaux donc c'est
quoi finalement prendre proportionnelle
intégrale et le parti arrivant oui le
parti qui arrive en tête à une prime à
une prime de 30% conquet bon c'est assez
simple à comprendre c'est donc ce qui
représente pas parfaitement les français
ba a parfaitement sûrement bien mieux
que ce qui existe aujourd'hui et
deuxièmement pour répondre à votre
question effectivement nous français on
pense toujours à la 4e république pour
la proportionnelle avec un nombre de
mines de gouvernement qui sont tombés
mais c'est marrant là aussi c'est que
les maquereaux nice utilisent toujours
l'allemagne en termes de modèles
économiques industrielles etc mais
jamais en matière démocratique en
allemagne c'est assez simple c'est un
proportionnelle il ya un gouvernement
qui est responsable
évidemment devant le parlement donc là
le chancelier ou la chancelière est
responsable devant le parlement si le
gouvernement doit tomber il ya une
condition qui n'existe pas sous la
quatrième république c'est qu'avant qui
tombe il faut déjà qu'ils aient formé le
suivant et donc qu'il ya une stabilité
institutionnelle qui n'existait pas sur
la quatrième république c'est donc très
simple à stabiliser enfin sur la
pratique puisque vous en parlez mais
l'assemblée nationale sous emmanuel
macron c'était une catastrophe c'est une
chance et je vais vous dire je prends
tous les citoyens français où peu avoue
quand même avoir un point de vue quand
on est des acteurs politiques on n'est
pas des castors donc on réfléchit on
voit ce qui se passe et ce que j'ai
constaté c'est depuis 2015 une
multiplication des états d'urgence une
multiplication de la pratique des
conseils de défense est donc une
pouvoirs de l'assemblée à pouvoir
démocratique un pouvoir du débat
largement diminué en particulier sous
emmanuel macron mais aussi sous les
gouvernements socialistes qui
aujourd'hui soutient emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs amsalem un mot là-dessus je
crois que voilà c'est important de dire
que pour avoir cette fameuse oxygénation
démocratique sur laquelle je pense qu'il
ya vraiment consensus dans la société
dans le monde politique et c'est bien
parce que c'est nouveau il faut aussi
avoir en tête que
on peut pas opposer comme ça le
libéralisme et la démocratie
nécessairement une démocratie elle elle
doit préserver un tronc commun de
liberté et ça je pense qu'il faut
vraiment s'engager là dessus sur l'idée
qu'il y a des droits alors c'est vrai
qu'en france on n'a pas fait le choix de
déclarer des droits interrogeable mais
voilà je pense quand même qu'il ya un
acquis républicains révolutionnaire sur
lequel il faut s'engager en termes de
voix la de garantie citoyenne d'égalité
et je crois que c'est quelque chose
auquel les français sont quand même
sensiblement attaché il ya une deuxième
chose c'est que par contre sur la la la
les réformes qui seront menées je pense
qu'il faut s'engager sur une certaine
effectivité consulter le peuple c'est
une bonne chose mais c'est pas ça la
garantie de la vivacité démocratique
c'est aussi que les commissions qu'on
engage et bien finalement propose des
résultats que les référendum sur
lesquels on s'engage et bien soit amène
parce que le seul référendum qu'on a
connus qui fonctionne c'est le
référendum gaulliste elle référendum
gaulliste c'est quoi c'est un outil de
responsabilités c'est-à-dire à partir du
moment où cette question ne fonctionne
plus j'en fais un pouvoir d'engagement
personnel et dans ce cas là la confiance
en moi il rompu et je m'en vais donc
soit on réactive finalement un
référendum qui qui sert à une
gouvernance avec aussi des pouvoirs
publics et qui sont capables d'enchaîner
dernière parce que le brésil font en
reparler c'est quand même un référendum
où on a eu l'idée de consulter le peuple
mais où la politique derrière n'a pas
suivi donc il faut que les deux aille de
pair c'est quand même très simple et on
termine sur la question du
du septennat avec un échange entre les
deux candidats et qui a duré sur sur
deux jours septennat renouvelables non
renouvelables écoutez je fais pas un
septennat non renouvelables parce que je
pense oui le quinquennat a eu des
conséquences extrêmement néfaste sur l'
équilibre de nos institutions moi je
suis plutôt favorable au septennat moi
j'ai toujours tendance à penser que le
caractère renouvelable non renouvelables
ça dépend du peuple on peut limiter dans
le temps mais dire c'est une fois cet
étrange c'est la première fois que
j'entends emmanuel macron évoqué le
septennat
je sais pas s'il est non renouvelable ou
pas dans son esprit ah oui d'accord donc
ce serait un septennat renouvelables
c'est ça le septennat me paraissait une
une bonne option mais il ne vaudra de
toute façon pas pour le mandat qui vient
d'évidence ya le bon une pile et
emmanuel macron ne serait pas quand même
en train de courir derrière marine le
pen sur cette question deux septennats
je crois pas non non je crois pas on
voit bien que cette question du mandat
de la durée du mandat présidentiel
revient systématiquement dans les
questions institutionnelles parce
qu'elle permettrait le découplage avec
les élections législatives c'est ça
l'objectif c'est d'avoir des élections
législatives qui pourraient intervenir
un peu à mi mandat et qui permette à
nouveau on dit tous à la recherche de
cette respiration démocratique et donc
il faut trouver le bon équilibre donc la
piste de revenir sur le sur le septennat
en est une certaines commissions qui
avaient réfléchir nos institutions
l'avait proposé il ya bien longtemps je
crois que chevènement également le
projet proposé assez récemment moi je
pense que ça s'il faudrait en débattre
personnellement moi j'étais plus sur une
autre ligne mais en tout cas la durée ce
qui est intéressant c'est le découplage
législatives présidentielles ça ça peut
produire un effet certain et de pouvoir
s'inscrire dans une dans une durée plus
longue pour le président de la
république pour ce qui l'a amené à mener
des enjeux beaucoup plus cruciaux et sur
le long terme on comprend bien
minutes pour conclure sur cette question
deux septennats non renouvelables seront
classés simplement c'est que durant
toutela la campagne le programme des
manuels battre on s'est résumée à la
réforme des retraite de 60 à 65 ans je
constate aujourd'hui que quand on
propose une réforme institutionnelle il
fait ses courses à l'intérieur
septennat non renouvelable bien
évidemment je pense que la pratique du
pouvoir lui a démontré que un mandat de
cinq ans n'est pas suffisant parce qu'il
est élu et parce qu'à mi-mandat il
commence déjà à réfléchir à sa
réélection et je pense que le
quinquennat et l'inversion du calendrier
c'est à dire présidentielle législative
abouti à une chose l'assemblée nationale
est une chambre d'enregistrement dans la
pratique on arrive aux arguments aux uns
et aux autres merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce débat